c'est William le prince William et Kate
Middleton ils sont dans leur chambre à
coucher ça fait 11 ans qui sont mariés
là on le sait ils sont mariés en 2011 et
Ken
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
la blague est terminée ou pas
[Applaudissements]
petit truc qu'il adore faire ça dans le
noir le noir le plus complet ah celui
qui en a un peu marre il y a quelques
mois bah elle a décidé d'ouvrir la
lumière et là si tu portes tremblement
qu'est-ce qu'elle voit qu'en réalité bah
William il utilise un sextoys
pourquoi est-ce que tu fais ça il faut
que tu m'expliques s'il te plaît
explique-moi alors William l'arrière de
lui dire ok ok je vais t'expliquer le
sex toys et toi tu vas m'expliquer notre
adresse
[Musique]
c'est la première fois c'est la première
fois que le début d'une blague est plus
drôle que la chute
Bertrand alors vous savez que le roi
Charles III il parle très bien
pas beaucoup voir même pas du tout alors
ça il lui a dit récemment écoute le
camion a vraiment ça va pas tu as des
trop grosses lacunes je vais te donner
des leçons tous les jours que tu vas
apprendre en mot et ce mot tu vas devoir
le reconstituer dans une phrase
commençons par soleil
je réfléchis une heure après elle
revient le soleil était de sortie oh
parfait car il n'y a parfait on va
passer au stade supérieur un peu plus
compliqué mouton mouton faut que je
réfléchisse Charles s'en va Charles
revient tu écoutes ou Charles c'est pas
compliqué mouton nous tombe
le soir à Clarence cette fois et bien à
nouveau il
[Applaudissements]
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé le mot ah bon
mais quoi quel est ce mot il est mou ton
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
alors si c'est l'Angleterre non
[Rires]
en anglais et en Belgique toujours les
Américains les Anglais
et à Londres et l'anglais du voyage
quand même sympa l'Angleterre
vous offrez une bière on vous offre une
bière vous ré-offrez une bière on vous
ré-offre une bière Star Wars
vous offrez une bière on vous ré-offre
de bières pour réoffrir une bière on
vous ré-offre deux pierres le Bel
n'importe quoi mais n'importe le vrai
pays du savoir recevoir c'est la
Belgique ça à Bruxelles à Bruxelles vous
offrez une bière on vous offre une
pierre dix pierres sans bière et après
vous allez [ __ ]
gratuitement
répond le Belge pas moi mais ma sœur
elle ça lui arrive à chaque fois
[Applaudissements]
alors une blague avec les Anglais pour
changer en Belgique nous en été on a à
peuple comment dire c'est pas une
tradition mais un truc un peu drôle dans
les fesses les Belges les femmes belges
à la fin des soirées elle s'assait sur
les barbecues
[Applaudissements]
voyage officiel ça Majesté la Reine
reçoit le président de la République et
la tradition veut que elle escorte elle
vient chercher le président français à
la gare en carrosse et il remonte jusque
Buckingham Palace il s'installe dans la
voiture la reine fait signe et un moment
donné
flatulence énorme dans des cheveux dans
des chevaux ça pète ça sent énormément
elle continue à saluer elle dit
je suis désolé monsieur le Président et
Jacques Chirac la regarde pas de
problème j'ai cru que c'était un cheval
Votre Majesté
[Applaudissements]